[Musique]
hidalgo and 62 ans candidate socialiste
à cette élection c'est votre première
présidentielle bonjour et bienvenue à
mme hidalgo merci à vous nous allons
voyager ensemble dans les archives de
l'ina pour mettre à jour votre adn avec
d'abord vos premières apparitions
médiatiques rubrique big bang
lors de votre toute première vous
exercez un métier de l'ombre conseillère
technique dans un cabinet ministériel
sous le gouvernement de lionel jospin
vous travaillez pour la secrétaire
d'état aux droits des femmes et à la
formation professionnelle nicole péry
nous sommes en 1998 nous avait 39 ans je
crois qu'on est tous conscients ici que
les liens entre emploi et formation
entre travail et formation sont telles
que le sujet ne peut pas être
complètement autonome même si et je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
aussi dans un travail de nicole il faut
qu'on arrive à redéfinir quand même les
finalités propre de la formation vous
souvenez de ce moment de cette première
samira je me souviens de pas vraiment en
fait de ce moment je me souviens bien
sûr j'étais au cabinet de nicole péry et
de martine aubry puisque c'était le même
ministère et nicole péry et nommé
à la formation professionnelle
on n'est pas très nombreux autour d'elle
à ce moment là et je me souviens qu'on
est en train d'essayer de définir
ce qu il faut faire une réforme une
grande réforme accompagner on était
aussi dans dans la loi sur les 35 heures
est un peu plus tard une école perry va
devenir aussi secrétaire d'état aux
droits des femmes
mais voilà je me souviens tout de moi
c'était pas quand même vous vous lancer
en politique à paris lors des
municipales de 2001 vous conduisiez la
liste du ps dans le 15e arrondissement
face à edouard balladur et assumé des
responsabilités
au ministère du travail auprès de
martine aubry aujourd'hui auprès de
marylise lebranchu je me sens tout à
fait fort mais est prête à assumer un
mandat de maire sinon je me serais pas
présenté un ça je vous le garantis
comment ça s'est passé qu'est ce qui
vous a donné envie de vous présenter une
et en fait c'est vrai que vous m'avez vu
avant j'étais dans un rôle de
conseillère technique j'ai toute ma vie
j'ai travaillé au ministère du travail
j'ai été inspectrice du travail puis
spécialiste des questions d'emploi et de
formation
et puis au cabinet de martine aubry on
porte autour de lionel jospin la réforme
sur la parité la loi la grande loi sur
la parité et à ce moment là que ce soit
martine aubry marylise lebranchu ou
nicole péry elles me disent voilà on a
besoin maintenant de femmes qui sont
formés qui vont venir dans la bataille
des municipales qui s'annonce il faut
que tu y ait eu à une expérience on a
besoin de femmes comme toi sur les
listes aux municipales
moi j'étais parisienne je voyais déjà
que se profilent et la bataille de paris
avec bertrand delanoë que je ne
connaissais pas personnellement mais qui
portait pour moi vraiment ce que je
voulais dans les transformations de
paris je suis allé le voir je me suis
battue parce que c'est une primaire pour
emporter la tête de liste dans le 15e
arrondissement et je me souviens alors
c'était évidemment personne ne me
connaissait jeu débarquer dans un fief
de la droite avec edouard balladur quand
même qu'ils étaient encore tout auréolé
1 2 voilà de sa fonction de premier
ministre de grands leaders de la droite
et moi je passais dans les rues du 15e
en disant bonjour je suis anne hidalgo
candidate du parti socialiste
et voilà j'ai fait mes premières armes
comme ça et j'ai été élu voilà j'ai créé
la surprise en ayant notamment un
deuxième temps parce que là on était
dans un fief où on passait jamais le
deuxième tour la gauche élu au conseil
de paris mais vous ne gagnez pas la
mairie du xvème non mais comme la gauche
devient majoritaire à paris le nouveau
maire bertrand delanoë fait de vous sa
première adjointe en charge de la parité
femmes hommes et du bureau des temps
problématique qu'illustraient à l'époque
par ce reportage
et si le marché en bas de chez vous et
est ouvert toute la journée si votre
bibliothèque ou votre piscine vous
accorder un peu plus de temps s'il y
avait plus de métro au vrai heures de
pointe ou bien des bureaux de la mairie
ouvert après 18 heures autrement dit si
les services publics adaptés un peu
mieux leurs horaires aux vôtres c'est la
réflexion que mène actuellement l'hôtel
de ville telles expériences menées dans
tel quartier dans telle structure a tenu
dans l arrondissement fera peut-être
tâche d'huile mais en ayant bien
conscience que ya pas de solution toute
faite pour tout paris c'est à dire que
la solution qu'on aura trouvée dans
telles crèches du 9e arrondissement ne
sera pas forcément transposable parce
que ne correspondant pas aux besoins du
15e ou au besoin de telles crèches des
19e le bureau du temps aura des antennes
dans chaque arrondissement pour engager
le vaste débat sur la gestion de ce
temps et justement ça risque peut-être
d'en prendre du temps cette charge du
bureau du temps vous a valu le surnom
moqueur d'horloge parlante c'est une
fonction gadget non pas du tout
d'ailleurs on voit bien en 2001 ont créé
quelque chose de très moderne les femmes
arrivent dans la vie politique
municipale à paris je suis première
adjointe élue et je porte d'ailleurs ce
projet sur l'égalité femmes hommes il y
a dans l'égalité femmes hommes
évidemment la question de l'articulation
de la vie familiale et de la vie
professionnelle
mais pour un monde politique un peu
classique c'est à ce moment là alors
c'est les quolibets en veux tu en voilà
c'est elle s'occupe des problèmes de
bonne femme ça n'a aucun sens ça n'est
pas politique donc je me prends et dans
je dirais le landerneau politique et
médiatique beaucoup beaucoup de
critiques mais vous savez c'est pas
grave je sais que quand on a des idées
qui sont des idées parfois un peu
très progressiste qui sont précurseurs
parce que ce bureau des temps c'est
quelque chose qui avance est beaucoup
dans les pays du nord de l'europe qui
était portée beaucoup par les féministes
italienne et qui en fait permettait
vraiment d'articuler vie familiale et
vie professionnelle pour moi c'était une
façon aussi de me battre d'accompagner
d'aider les parisiennes à vivre au mieux
parce que je connais c'est la galère la
galère de la mère de famille qui courent
toute la journée pour essayer
voilà de tout faire et de s'occuper
aussi de ses enfants treize ans plus
tard vous devenez la première femme
maire de paris nous sommes le 5 avril
[Musique]
elle goûte avec sourire à ses seconds
qui font d'elle la première femme maire
de l'histoire de paris
anne hidalgo fidèles première-adjointe
dans l'ombre de bertrand delanoë depuis
2001 entre dans la lumière est prononcé
tout premiers mots de mer face au
conseil de paris qui vient de l'élire
c'est avec fierté que je reçois cet
immense et belle responsabilité
c'est avec fidélité que je l'assumerai
chaque jour au cours des six prochaines
années à quoi ou à qui est ce que vous
pensez à ce moment là bas à ce moment là
j'ai mon père qui est en tribunes il a
85 ans est quasiment le jour de son
anniversaire
je pense à ma famille je pense vraiment
voilà je viens
de l'immigration espagnole d'un milieu
très modeste je viens
voilà d'un milieu ouvrier et rien ne me
prédestinait à être là vous savez on est
quand même dans un monde où la
reproduction sociale et et à tous les
étages gelé connu j'ai bossé toute ma
vie j'ai beaucoup bossé j'ai essayé de
le faire voilà en étant
toujours au rendez vous fidèle à mes
valeurs et puis en le faisant sans
mauvais coups que j'ai jamais aimé la
politique des salles coup je me suis
toujours inscrits et pour ça et bertrand
delanoë et martine aubry ou encore
lionel jospin ont été pour moi des
exemples de on fait de la politique pour
changer la vie des gens par d'abord des
réalités on propose et ont fait bouger
les choses donc je pense à ma famille et
surtout à mes parents qui sont dans la
tribune à ce moment là alors puisque
vous les citer à l'ondé t revo racines
vous quitter l'espagne franquiste à
l'âge de deux ans votre famille décidant
62 d'émigrer en france dans la région de
lyon voici un programme de l'oim rtf à
destination de la jeunesse 16 million de
jeunes sur la guerre d'espagne et l'exil
du chanteur paco ibanez
[Musique]
18 juillet
c'est l'espagne de 1936
[Musique]
une moitié de l'espagne l'heure de la
main de l'autre
dans l'historie de gwen dans aia
ça veut dire ça veut dire nous sommes
qui nous sommes von ah on est fatigué
d'entendre toujours toujours la même
chose de toujours d'être tourné vers le
passé on a on connaît le passé on n'a
pas besoin de l'évoquer il est déjà dans
notre sens dans notre dans nos attitudes
dans tout le nouvel avenir et faisons
quelque chose ensemble et les morts ils
sont morts et on sait qu'ils sont morts
mais c'est pas parce qu'on pense tout le
temps aux morts et que qu'on leur rend
un service finalement la meilleur
service qu'on peut le rendre c'est de
faire ce qu'ils ont ils auraient voulu
faire c'est ça
regardez devant arrêter de se retourner
de parler du passé est ce que vous
partagez ou est ce que vous faites votre
le précepte de paco ibanez et paco
ibanez que j'aime beaucoup et que je
connais bien et bien sûr qu'il faut
regarder devant vous savez il faut
connaître son histoire connaître
l'histoire savoir pourquoi il y a eu
cette guerre ce qu'elle a produit ce
qu'a été aussi franco le martyre de
toutes ces femmes et ces hommes mes
grands parents qui partent paternel qui
avaient fui la région de malaga qui ont
échappé à ces massacres qui sont
retrouvés dans des camps de réfugiés ici
en france mais en même temps il a tout à
fait raison de dire
regardons l'avenir j'étais très ami avec
étienne roda-gil qui qui était voilà ce
parolier cet artiste extraordinaire qui
avait une vie aussi de réfugiés
puisqu'il était né dans un des camps de
réfugiés espagnols et un jour après ma
victoire ma première victoire à paris à
l'hôtel de ville en 2001 comme
adjointe première adjointe il m'a dit tu
sais où tu est la preuve vivante que
franco avait tort et parce que tu es là
tu vie parce que parce que tu as montré
aussi cette force quand on connaît son
histoire cette force d'aller de l'avant
et puis de construire l'avenir est
d'essayer d'être généreux d'essayer de
faire en sorte que des enfants qui
aujourd'hui connaissent sans doute aussi
où la pauvreté ou la difficulté ou la
guerre pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux qui est qu'ils peuvent qu il doive
qu'on doit être nous les adultes tourner
vers eux les accompagner pour qu'ils
puissent construire leur avenir le plus
librement possible sans être déterminée
par une histoire l'histoire de leur
famille l'histoire de leur pays si leur
pays n'est pas la france ou même
d'histoire de la france et qu'on doit se
donner cette liberté cette émancipation
mais elle n'est possible que si il y à
de l'éducation de la culture et si on
connaît l'histoire votre premier métier
c'est vous l'avez dit inspectrice du
travail vous êtes l'une des rares femmes
à être reçus au concours national en 81
2 regardez comment l'eau et rtf dans une
émission intitulée un homme de
conciliation raconte la journée d'un
inspecteur du travail monsieur bussières
shérif en deux chevaux on les appelait
nous sommes en 1969 j'avais une dose
suffit surtout vous appelle monsieur
l'inspecteur et vous n'appartenez pas la
police quel genre d'inspecteurs et tout
est bien je suis d'abord un inspecteur
du travail et du coup un inspecteur du
parec esprit là rien à voir ni avec le
fisc mais avec la police en fait
j'appartiens à un corps qui a été créé à
l'origine pour s'assurer que
soit respecté l'interdiction d'emploi
des enfants avant un certain âge
prospectivement cette fonction s'est
développée et des inspecteurs du travail
ont été amenés à contrôler les
conditions de travail on sait respecter
les conditions d'hygiène et de sécurité
du travail
ça correspond à ce que vous avez fait
oui j'avais même une deux chevaux comme
ça dans le val de marne aussi puisque
j'ai été mon premier poste dans le val
de marne c'est un très beau métier vous
savez d'ailleurs évidemment moi je viens
de ce milieu ouvrier mon père était
ouvrier électricien et il était aussi à
la fin de deux ans plus tard dans sa vie
syndicaliste secrétaire d'un comité
d'entreprise et quand j'avais 16 ans
j'avais fait un stage dans sa boîte dans
les services de comptabilité il y avait
à l'époque un chef du personnel qui
était d'origine italienne et il me
disait tu sais il ya un métier
extraordinaire regarde regarde toi qui
t'intéresse son monde du travail et qui
est un métier très utile c'est le métier
d'inspecteur du travail c'est le premier
qui m'a parlé de ce métier là j'avais 16
ans et c'était un chef du personnel
ensuite je me suis passionné pour le
droit du travail j'ai vraiment eu envie
d'être utile de j'étais très très
intéressé par ce monde professionnel il
y avait des mutations dans les années où
j'ai fait mes études de droit du travail
et quand j'ai exercé comme inspectrice
du travail il y avait des grandes
mutations la sidérurgie la métallurgie
la chimie et je m'intéressais à la fois
bien sûr aux conditions de travail mais
aussi à l'évolution de ce monde du
travail dans lequel j'ai pris ma part
j'ai eu un immense plaisir j'ai
tellement appris tellement appris de ces
situations réelles et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque les inspecteurs du travail
avait eu un article dans le monde sur
les les inspecteurs les shérifs en deux
chevaux et mon premier stage que je fais
j'étais étudiante à lyon iii en droit du
travail et le premier stage que je fais
et à saint-etienne avec des inspecteurs
du travail qui était presque tous à la c
fdt qui était hyper engagé intéressant
qui m'ont emmené dans des entreprises
dans la mine la mine qui a fermé peu de
temps après que j'ai pu la visiter bref
j'ai tellement appris jeu et puis aussi
une forme d'art de négociation parce que
ce métier là tous les cas à l'époque il
fallait aussi beaucoup beaucoup négocié
j'ai adoré cette cette fonction là et
cette expérience de vie vous avez la
double nationalité espagnole et
française donc puis voté des vo 18 ans
pour la présidentielle de 1981 et comme
tous les militants de gauche vous avez
été témoin depuis 40 ans des grandes
heures puis de l'effondrement du parti
socialiste
3 2 1
françois mitterrand est élu président de
la république
51,7 %
voilà donc l'image de ce nouveau
président de la république françois
mitterrand vient d'être réélu
vous voyez donc jacques chirac 19 9%
jean marie le pen
17,9 pour cent et lionel jospin 16,1
j'assume pleinement la responsabilité de
cet échec et j'en tire les conclusions
en me retirant de la vie politique après
la presse
après la fin de l'élection
présidentielle nicolas sarkozy dont les
résidents de la république
tu ségolène royal
bacchus 53 donc pour nicolas sarkozy 47
d'un sport ségolène royal troisième
présidentielle perdue après 95 et
l'absence au deuxième tour en 2002 ça
fait beaucoup c'est françois hollande
qui est élu président de la république
avec
51,9 % des fois on attendait depuis
longtemps depuis longtemps mais je suis
content sarkozy sont dans la paix c'est
génial
6,4 pour cent pour benoît hamon jamais
candidat socialiste n'était tombé aussi
bas
qui stoppera cette descente aux enfers
anne hidalgo vous d'abord vous savez
c'est un long processus et si on reprend
l'élection de françois mitterrand en 81
qui a été une explosion de joie moi
j'avais une vingtaine d'années j'étais à
lyon à ce moment là c'est tout d'un coup
une liberté qui arrive quelque chose qui
s'ouvre dans le pays les libertés
publiques la décentralisation les lois
sur le travail
immédiatement les lois auroux c'est un
moment très fort mais qui vient de loin
qui vient d'une longue quête d'un homme
qui a su patiemment d'abord labour et la
france
réunir rassembler créer les conditions
évidemment d'une union parce que
c'est évident qu'on ne peut pas gagner à
gauche dans notre pays s'il n'y a pas
d'unité est il à supporter cela ensuite
on a eu les moments difficiles le moment
de 2002 avec cette élection
on n'est pas au second tour alors que
lionel jospin était premier ministre un
premier ministre qui avait redresser le
pays qui a fait un travail exceptionnel
mais quand même une division de la
gauche qui est là un travail qui se fait
tout de suite derrière qui ne va pas
permettre d'aller à la victoire en 2007
même si le score de ségolène royal est
un score très très important et puis et
puis françois hollande qui gagne là
aussi sur un élan sur un moment fort j'y
étais j'ai fait partie de son équipe de
campagne
il ya eu un quinquennat avec des grandes
réussites et des choses difficiles donc
mais françois hollande c'était il ya dix
ans c'était il ya dire dire grande
victoire c'est un chiot mâle du parti
société il ya dix ans et l'élection de
2017 qui a été une élection à la fois
très particulière où
là benoît hamon c'est le score du ps et
des verts ainsi 4 1 à ce moment là
puisqu'il ya une une candidature commune
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire moi je pense
d'abord la fidélité à son histoire à ses
valeurs ce qui veut pas dire les
solutions du passé mais quand même la
fidélité ce que je porte dans cette
élection présidentielle c'est héritage
de cette gauche républicaine européenne
social socialiste qui a fait siennes les
questions d'écologie et qui veut
gouverner et transformer le monde et
améliorer la vie des françaises et des
français je pense qu'on est encore dans
le tumulte la difficulté évidemment on
l'a vu il n'a pas été possible de se
rassembler avec la gauche des
discussions ont eu lieu mais elles n'ont
pas abouti
je pense que cette élection là est une
élection qui s'inscrit dans quelque
chose encore de très difficile et je
porte je porte cette cette campagne dans
ce contexte avec beaucoup de lucidité
mais je sais que ce que nous sommes en
train de faire aujourd'hui va nous
permettre de construire quelque chose
parce que ce que nous portons c'est la
voix d'une gauche qui a toujours été
présente dans la république et quand
elle n'est pas présente dans la
république elle a toujours été là pour
les grandes conquêtes les a lancé le
monde politique et médiatique a beaucoup
changé ces dernières années mais pour
autant je pense et je porte cette ce
message là les classes moyennes les
catégories populaires qui aujourd'hui
souffrent d'une injustice sociale
terrible parce que nous sommes dans un
pays où il ya beaucoup trop d'injustice
où
il risque d'y en avoir encore plus parce
que les projets que je vois sur la
retraite les projets que je vois sur le
démantèlement de l'école sont des choses
qui vont encore affaiblir ce qui fait
pour moi la force de la france
c'est-à-dire risque ses services publics
de faire risque de disparition du peu je
crois qu'il y aurait eu un risque de
disparition si le ps n'avait pas été
enfin si cette gauche républicaine
sociale et européenne n'avait pas été
présent dans cette élection elle est là
beaucoup de femmes et d'hommes me disent
bien sûr que c'est difficile on est
présent dans les territoires un très
présent dans les territoires puisque si
vous regardez la carte électorale dans
les communes les départements ou les
régions le ps pèse environ 15% mais
c'est vrai que du local au national
on n'a pas encore réussi à faire
complètement cette mutation elle
nécessitait et elle nécessite cette
présence aujourd'hui dans cette élection
très très difficile très particulière de
2022 pour permettre justement d'ouvrir
une nouvelle page dans tous les cas de
façon très lucide très responsable très
consciente de la difficulté de la tâche
dans laquelle avec d'autres je me suis
lancée que cette difficulté de tâches
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui est
celle qui doit permettre d'ouvrir un
nouvel espace à ce que j'appelle cette
gauche républicaine européenne
qui a intégré l'écologie et vous savez
la gauche dans notre pays ne gagne
jamais par les extrêmes elle ne gagne
jamais ni par le témoignage ou
l'exclusive protestation elle gagne
lorsqu'elle a envie de gouverner
lorsqu'elle s'inscrit aussi dans
l'histoire du pays dans ce qui fait
notre république je suis une
républicaine vraiment absolue pour moi
la république elle est aussi laïque elle
est laïque et sociale c'est l'un et
l'autre c'est pas l'un sans l'autre et
c'est ce que nous devons porter ce que
je porte dans cette campagne mais ce que
je vais porter et vous verrez qu'au
lendemain aussi de cette élection quel
qu'en soit le résultat
beaucoup beaucoup d'initiatives vont se
déployer sur le territoire en france en
lien avec nos amis les sociaux
démocrates qui gouvernent partout
ailleurs dans beaucoup de pays européens
pour reconstruire cette proposition
absolument indispensable et dans les
autres pays je pense l'espagne je pense
le portugal ou d'autres il a fallu
parfois dix ans voire plus de 10 ans
pour pouvoir reconstruire cette offre
politique là et bien c'est le travail
auquel je me suis attelé dès cette
campagne présidentielle voyons-y sont
vos mentors
bayonne à bord une femme martine aubry
mais qui vous avez travaillé lorsqu'elle
était ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité et que vous soutenez lors de
la primaire socialiste de 2011
anne hidalgo à l'honneur elle est la
seule politique en photo dans la lettre
de martine aubry va distribuer aux
français
reste la chance de l'avoir dans mon
équipe au ministère j'ai toujours dit
que c'était un peu ma petite soeur en
politique vraiment plus petite elle est
plus jeune que moi bien évidemment
martine aubry votre grande soeur en
politique oui oh oui même plus que ça
parce que c'est vrai que moi j'ai
beaucoup appris avec elle j'ai appris en
étant sa conseillère j'ai appris l'école
de l'exigence parce que martin il
fallait être au carré les dossiers sa
supposée pas la moindre petite ambiguïté
ou hésitation donc j'ai appris ça puis
j'ai appris aussi de cette femme voilà
avec ce caractère avec cet engagement
cette personnalité aussi un qui est une
personnalité qui entre sa vie
personnelle et sa vie politique fait je
dirais ce qu'elle dit et il ya des
grands voilà moi je l' ai vu accueillir
chez elle des enfants des enfants des
quartiers populaires de l'île les élever
les accompagner dans leurs études voilà
je la vois aussi s'engager sur sur les
réfugiés elle n'hésite jamais à y mettre
aussi de sa vie personnelle donc c'est
quelqu'un qui moi m'a beaucoup appris et
puis qui est là qui est là aujourd'hui
aussi dans ce moment qui est plus
difficile évidemment pour pour la gauche
et qui voit là je c'est une grande dame
une très très grande dame
malheureusement dans notre pays je pense
que voilà les grandes dames en politique
ont encore du mal à percer mais voilà
mais elle est là en tous les cas et dans
ma vie elle est là l'autre mentor c'est
celui qui vous installer à ses côtés
pendant 13 ans bertrand delanoë voici ce
qu'il dit de vous lors de la campagne
municipale de 2008
alors hidalgo maire bis en tout cas lors
d'un meeting dans l'arrondissement où
elle est élue le 15e d'airtran de la
noue et a accordé à sa première adjointe
une place de choix
débrouille elle a du caractère je vous
dirais la d'autorité mais toujours d'une
douceur et donc je sais qu'elle est
meilleure que moi bertrand delanoë à qui
vous avez succédé et avec qui vous avez
rompu à moins que ce ne soit le
contraire qu est-ce que s'est il passé
entre eux non non moi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour bertrand il m'a aussi
fait confiance j'ai lu aussi c'est une
école de l'exigence dans cette ville de
paris où j'ai tout appris il m'a donné
cette chance que j'ai saisi aussi de
comprendre de travailler en profondeur
13 ans 13 ans 1re adjointe à être à ses
côtés à le défendre tout le temps parce
qu'il a été aussi très attaquées et à
apprendre
cette cette vie des lui cette vie
politique par quelque chose de très
concret aussi ensuite en 2017 il a fait
un choix un choix pour la présidentielle
d'ailleurs qu'un mac ronde et emmanuel
macron voilà c'est un choix que je
respecte et puis on voit là on s'est vu
un peu moins chacun a pris un chemin
s'éloigner aujourd'hui on ne se voit pas
tous les jours ça c'est clair mais je
garde de toute façon pour lui une
immense affection et un immense respect
quels que soient les choix respectifs
qu'on ait pu faire anne hidalgo comme
chaque candidat nous allons vous placer
face à de gaulle
parce que beaucoup s'en réclament
dans cette campagne entre les deux tours
de la présidentielle 2,65 alors qu'il
affronte françois mitterrand charles de
gaulle parle ainsi de la france de la
droite et de la gauche
la franche c'est tout à la fois c'est
tous les français
c'est pas la gauche la france c'est pas
la droite la france
naturellement les français comme de tout
haut ils ont tu
as entre temps de quoi il y à l'éternel
courant du mouvement
qui va aux réformes qui va au changement
qui est naturellement nécessaire et puis
aussi un courant de l'ordre la règle de
la tradition kg si nécessaire j'étais
avec tout ça qu'on fait la france oui
complètement d'accord avec lui c'est
avec tout ça qu'on fait la france et les
deux sont nécessaires évidemment jeu
pour moi le général de gaulle c'est
d'abord l'homme de juin 40 c'est ce
courage immense et le chef de de la
france de la france libre c'est l'homme
qui arrive à soulever cette armée a
rassemblé aussi à réunir tous les
courants de la résistance à les unifier
et c'est l'homme de la libération
l'homme de la libération de paris parce
qu'il décide aussi et il fait tout ce
qu'il faut pour venir soutenir libéré
paris
après cette insurrection sachant qu'
évidemment il y avait cette proposition
des américains de filer tout de suite
vers le front est mais qu'il qu'il fait
en sorte que paris soit libéré et puis
c'est l'homme qui parce qu'il l'avait
acquis aussi cette stature dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire de et dans le
coeur de toutes les françaises et les
français cette capacité à dire que la
france c'est tout ça la france s'est
effectivement ces femmes et ces hommes
de gauche ces femmes et ces hommes de
droite c'est le côté conservateur et le
comté progressiste et c'est tout à la
fois et je pense qu'il a raison de
rappeler ce qu'est la fonction enfin la
france et à partir de là ce qu'est la
fonction présidentielle en tous les cas
il là il l'a incarné comme nul autre
n'aura pu l'incarner après lui rubriques
suivantes
180 degrés c'est la séquence des
revirements où des reniements le vôtre
date d'il y à un peu moins de deux ans
le 25 juin 2020 vous êtes en campagne
pour votre réélection à la mairie de
paris
redoutable candidat à la présidence
s'il le dit non je surtout pas gelé dit
très précisément moi je considère et ont
tout à l'heure pascal durand le disait
très très bien je considère qu'il ya un
endroit où on peut à gv aujourd'hui
c'est un endroit très stratégique c'est
celui des villes est ce que vous n'avez
pas tromper les électeurs parisiens qui
vous avait promis que ce serait paris à
100% non vous savez d'abord beaucoup
d'électeurs parisien me disais déjà
pendant la campagne surtout surtout ne
dit pas jamais parce que on voudra aussi
que vous soyez candidate à la
présidentielle et vous avez déjà mais
j'ai dit jamais et je ce n'est pas un
reniement vous savez à un moment donné
bien sûr là je suis sincère et dans ma
vie moi je suis pas je n'ai pas grandi
en me disant je serai présidente de la
république un jour où je serai candidate
à l'élection présidentielle
j'ai choisi d'ailleurs souvent quand on
m'a proposé d'être ministre françois
hollande me l'avait proposé j'ai dit non
à l'époque on avait aussi proposé de
prendre la tête du parti socialiste j'ai
dit non parce que c'était pour moi paris
qui était l'enjeu numéro un et puis à un
moment donné vous faites partie d'une
famille d'une famille de pensée d'une
famille de pensée dans laquelle vous
vous dites je ne peux pas rester
simplement à regarder ce qui va se
passer dans cette présidentielle
je pense je le dis si le parti
socialiste la gauche républicaine et
européennes que j'incarne dans cette
élection n'avait pas été candidate alors
là c'est l effacement et la disparition
totale et je me suis je me suis
dit qu'il y avait évidemment d'abord à
répondre à cette attente puisque c'est
pas moi qui me suis levé un matin mais
beaucoup de gens qui sont venus me
chercher pour que je prenne cette
responsabilité et j'ai pris cette
responsabilité qui est aussi une
responsabilité parce que je pense que
notre pays ne pourra pas se passer
d'avoir cette gauche républicaine
européenne laïque écologique et sociale
dans le pays que qu'il ya un
déséquilibre on le voit déjà aujourd'hui
ce déséquilibre je ne crois pas aux
extrêmes je ne crois pas au populisme
je crois vraiment comme le disait tout à
l'heure le général de gaulle qui lient à
ces deux forces qui sont là qui doivent
être reconnus dans ce qu'elles sont une
force plus progressistes et une force
plus
conservatrice que ces deux forces la
structure notre vie politique et
permettent justement aussi de rassembler
les françaises et les français autour de
projets pas simplement autour d'un homme
mais autour de projets et donc j'ai pris
mes responsabilités et je vais vous dire
patrick cohen je regrette pas de les
avoir prises bien sûr que c'est très
difficile bien sûr que le contexte n'est
pas celui qui était le plus favorable
pour la candidate de cette gauche
républicaine que je suis mais je porte
c'est valeurs je porte ces propositions
vous aurez peut-être remarqué que dans
mes propositions il y à cette
orientation nouvelle où la question du
travail la question des classes moyennes
des catégories populaires est très
présente la question de l'écologie
évidemment et l'écologie pour
transformer la société notre économie
mais l'écologie toujours dans la justice
la question de la démocratie des
institutions toujours aussi dans l'idée
d'avoir un pays où la démocratie respire
qu'on sorte de cette monarchie
républicaine dans laquelle nous sommes
et dans laquelle nous avons sans doute
amplifié le phénomène ces cinq dernières
années donc voilà je crois à ces idées
là à cette force là et la politique
c'est de la construction c'est de la
construction humaine c'est de l'
aventure humaine sont des idées et c'est
dans cette filiation là que je m'inscris
paris encore dans la séquence zéro
pointé
réduire la place de la voiture c'est
louable mais empêcher les gens de
travailler c'est plus discutable voyez
ces artisans qui perdent du temps de
l'argent parfois une partie de leur
travail à cause des embouteillages
parisiens
sur le trajet de son prochain chantier
cet artisan à la boule au ventre le
temps qu'il va passer aujourd'hui dans
les embouteillages à paris sylvain
barreaud n'en a absolument aucune idée
au lieu d'anticiper
au maximum
mais quand il s'agit de faire les
comptes les bouchons ont un prix ils
font perdre 9000 euros tous les mois son
entreprise
au delà de ce manque à gagner bah c'est
quand même du temps fond on paye mais ça
enfin comment et qu'elles ont peiné
salariés c'est du temps aussi un peu de
stress pour nos salariés parce qu'ils
ont toujours cet aléa du bouchon cette
angoisse pour reprendre le mot du tout à
l'heure du premier jeu et même de temps
pour entrer ce soir les bouchons un
argument qui dissuaderait déjà un
artisan sur 10 d'intervenir au centre de
paris
trouver un électricien ou un plombier
dans la capitale pourrait donc bientôt
devenir le parcours du combattant excédé
par ce montant une association
d'automobilistes interpelle la mairie de
paris sur le temps passé dans les
bouchons notre mouvement s'appelle dit
le anne et on appelle tous les
automobilistes bloqués dans les bouchons
à prendre leur téléphone à connecter
leurs kits mali dans la voiture et
appeler anne hidalgo en direct pour lui
dire ce qu'ils vivent sur la route
votre politique municipale est elle un
handicap pour vous dans cette campagne
vous savez
j'ai comme beaucoup d'autres villes dans
le monde prie aussi un autre sujet qui
est très très important qui est celui de
la pollution qui dont les dégâts sont
incommensurables peut être moins visible
mais par exemple dans une ville comme
paris ses 2500 morts liés à la pollution
atmosphérique par an c'est beaucoup de
coups un pour notre système de santé et
donc j'ai pris évidemment le pari comme
toutes les grandes villes du monde et
d'ailleurs toutes les grandes villes du
pays de diminuer
la circulation automobile polluantes
notamment mais au bordeaux les parisiens
ont la sentiment d'avoir d'algues
que les bouchons aggrave la pollution
oui mais vous savez on est à l'ina et il
y a des ressources incroyables
impressionnante d'image que vous auriez
aussi pu passer dans l'histoire de paris
sur les bouchons parisiens et donc moi
je sais que le moment où on accomplit
une transformation on est dans le moment
de la transition c'est à dire on prend
conscience que la pollution ça tue et
que ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
d'ailleurs que tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
et que les habitants des métropoles et
d'une ville comme paris réclame de
pouvoir respirer qu'en plus on est à un
endroit où il existe des transports en
commun un métro à moins de dix minutes à
pied de chez vous c'est la chance qu'ont
les parisiens et bien la décision que
j'ai prise c'est aussi une décision qui
a été validé par le suffrage des
parisiens par deux fois par deux fois
une première fois en 2014 une deuxième
fois en 2020 et d'ailleurs qui m'a valu
aussi beaucoup de reconnaissance non
seulement des parisiens mais aussi à
l'international je pense un certain
nombre de reconnaissances y compris à
l'onu qui me valent et qui nous valent à
paris d'être justement dans une ville la
ville de l'accord de paris qui a su
prendre à bras le corps cette question
de la pollution du changement climatique
et de la nécessité de changer nos modes
de fonctionnement bien sûr que quand
vous êtes dans le moment où on change
c'est compliqué il faut adapter il faut
ajuster il faut trouver aussi par
exemple des adaptations pour ce que l'on
a fait ce que j'ai fait pour tous les
artisans les accompagner dans l'achat de
véhicules propres il ya une grande
transformation de la mobilité à
accomplir dans notre pays ce que je
propose d'ailleurs dans mon programme ce
que nous faisons tous les maires des
grandes villes en france et dans le
monde n'est pas transposable par exemple
dans des territoires ruraux donc il faut
inventer d'autres solutions permettre
l'achat
véhicule électrique donc ça veut dire
aussi organisées sur tout le territoire
l'existence de bornes et
d'infrastructures permettant ces
véhicules électriques c'est mettre en
place comme je le propose un leasing
sociale c'est-à-dire un accompagnement
pour ceux qui vivent dans les
territoires ruraux qui n'ont pas de
transports en commun de pouvoir avoir
accès à une location de véhicules
électriques qui leur coûtera moins cher
d'ailleurs compte tenu du prix de
l'essence bref ce sont des
transformations absolument indispensable
et paris est une ville d'innovation
c'est une ville moderne qui accompagnent
évidemment les artisans mais qui ne
pouvait pas rester en arrière de la
transformation écologique prenez les ce
qui s'est passé à rome qui est une ville
qui n'a pas connu les mêmes
transformations que paris rome a été
supplanté par qui par milan va nous
paris est devenue une référence mondiale
qui a attiré aussi beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont venus à paris
parce que justement j'avais cette
politique écologique très très très
avant gardiste et qui a montré ses
résultats vous avez rappelé votre
réélection
de 2020 à la tête de la mairie est ce
que votre score du 10 avril chez les
électeurs parisiens vous le regarderai
attentivement est-ce qu'il vaudra d'une
certaine façon approbation ou rejet de
votre action municipale non je crois que
vraiment les élections municipales sont
les élections municipales elles ont eu
lieu en 2020 et j'ai été élu et réélu
c'est un immense bonheur pour moi que
cela et puis ensuite il ya une élection
présidentielle bien sûr que je
regarderai mais une élection
présidentielle avec une gauche qui reste
extrêmement éparpillés alors que sur
paris j'avais réussi quand même à
rassembler cette gauche pas forcément au
premier tour puisque j'ai battu quand
même largement les verts mais au premier
tour mais ensuite on a pu se rassembler
donc c'est une élection très différentes
mais c'est une élection qui permettra
aussi je sais beaucoup de parisiennes et
parisiens de gauche écologistes ont
envie qu'il y ait un après qu'on ne se
résignent pas à un pays dans lequel
finalement l'injustice sociale soit la
règle dans lequel les classes moyennes
les catégories populaires soient
toujours celles qui payent le prix fort
de la crise ou alors une ville qui
serait dans un pays qui ne prendraient
pas au sérieux la question de la
transition écologique la planète brûle
la planète brûle vous pouvez pas rester
a expliqué qu' il est toujours temps
d'attendre et de transformer demain donc
bien sûr que ce qui sortira de cette
élection est une élection
présidentielle est donc nationale mais
permettra aussi je l'espère en tous les
cas la reconstruction demain de cette
gauche écologiste républicaine qui est
européenne qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
dans notre pays et et vous montrer ces
images là mais vous pouvez montrer aussi
les voies sur berge avec le bonheur des
parisiennes et des parisiens et de tous
ceux qui viennent visiter paris et qui
trouve beaucoup de plaisir aussi à avoir
cette ville cette ville modernisée qui
est une référence aujourd'hui dans le
monde une madeleine
une madeleine qui se nomme carmen
[Musique]
m
si
j'ai dit
[Musique]
non
lever une passion pour carmen en partie
en fait je pensais que c'était mais
c'est pas un extrait de cela mais j'ai
joué dans carmen j'avais 20 ans j'étais
à lyon je faisais partie de la troupe de
théâtre universitaire et c'était à
l'époque louis alaux directeur de
l'opéra de lyon qui avait monté sur au
théâtre romain de fourvière une mise en
scène de carmen assez extraordinaire par
tant de tableaux de goya les disparates
et avec la troupe de théâtre
universitaire je jouais ont joué
plusieurs rôles pendant cet opéra carmen
ça a été fabuleux parce que j'ai vécu
pendant deux mois et demi à la fois les
tout le travail de préparation et puis
les représentations avec les chanteurs
de l'opéra de lyon avec aussi tout toute
la troupe qui étaient sur place et
carmen c'est oui c'est une femme forte
c'est une femme puissante c'est une
femme qui est là qui vit sa vie en toute
liberté qui me rappelle aussi mon
espagne natale bien sûr puisque carmen
en fait historiquement elle était même à
cadix dans ma ville natale puisque c'est
là que se situe au départ lusine de
tabac dans laquelle travaille carmen
donc j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour pour
cette cet opéra et beaucoup de souvenirs
et beaucoup d'histoires avec une archive
à présent que nous proposons à tous les
candidats
celle de l' alerte verte c'est une
archive présidentielle de 74 avec un
candidat pas comme les autres et vous
savez ce qui va se passer eh bien nous
allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et c'est
pourquoi je bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer d'un projet
global d'avenir merci mes amis
rené dumont le candidat écolo qui n'a
pas été prise au sérieux des nox est
vrai pas même par les grands partis de
gauche non bien sûr mais moi j'avais 14
ans je me souviens vraiment de cette
scène on avait une télé noir et blanc
enfin je me souviens très bien de cette
scène et et pour moi ça a été le début
aussi d'une prise de conscience je suis
pas rentré je suis pas devenu écolo
à ce moment là je me suis pas intéressé
aux formations verte qui commençait à a
voilà exister dans le pays mais en
revanche il y avait du côté du ps eu du
côté de cette deuxième gauche beaucoup
de femmes et d'hommes je pense aussi à
huguette bouchardeau je pense d'une
certaine façon à michel rocard aussi qui
portait déjà ces questions d'écologie
alors ce n'était pas tellement sur l'eau
c'est vrai que lui rené dumont a été le
premier à le prendre sur cet angle là la
gauche et y compris cette deuxième
gauche le prenait plutôt sous l'angle du
développement et moi j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser vraiment à ce moment là
aussi à la politique et aux idées
sociales socialistes et écologistes mais
ça a été pour moi vraiment un
oui une alerte quelque chose qui à ce
moment là m'a ouvert vraiment sur cette
question de l'écologie et je m'en
souviens encore j'avais 14 ans une
rencontre enfin puiser dans la malle aux
trésors de l'ina
s'ils ne voient que nous voulions vous
faire entendre celle du neuropsychiatre
boris cyrulnik en 2001 il est sur le
plateau de bouillon de culture
l'émission de bernard pivot et il donne
une définition de la résilience
c'est un mot français qui vient du latin
recèlerait resauter qui est rebondir et
c'est un mot que les métallurgistes
laisser les sous-mariniers emploi tous
les jours c'est à dire qu'un métal garde
sa structure aux reprend sa structure
quelles que soient les coûts et
pressions du milieu donc c'est un mot
français très peu employée en france
jusqu'à maintenant mais très couramment
employées dans le langage quotidien dans
les pays anglo saxons diriez vous que
c'est une résiliente anne hidalgo vous
êtes fait d'un métal qui résiste aux
chocs je m'inscris complètement dans ce
que dit boris cyrulnik
d'ailleurs je les rencontre et j'ai eu
la chance de beaucoup
lire aussi tous ses livres oui je pense
que il le dit très clairement il faut
être soi même il faut avoir des
convictions évidemment ne pas vivre en
autarcie ou fermée aux autres il faut
accepter de se laisser aussi influencé
changé par les autres heureusement parce
que nous sommes des êtres sociaux et on
est tous interdépendants sans les autres
on n'est rien et en même temps il faut
être soi-même et savoir aussi résisté à
la violence des paroles à l'agressivité
et à la violence tout court savoir
résister aussi à des espèces
d'emportement d'emballement qui sont
quand même très dangereux où il faut
toujours quand même quelques voix qui a
peut-être je n'ai pas la solidité qui
est la mienne aujourd'hui je la puise
dans mes racines dans ma famille dans
mon histoire et puis je suis quelqu'un
qui aime profondément la vie
profondément les changes avec les autres
c'est tout ça qui fait une résilience
donc être résilience et accepter la vie
et en même temps pose est toujours
toujours les éléments de valeur et
d'essayer en tout cas ce que j'essaie de
faire d'aligner mes valeurs avec avec
ma vie est aussi dans la rencontre avec
les autres parce que je le redis tout
seul on est strictement rien au terme de
cet adn et de ce voyage dans les
archives de l'ina y at il un un morceau
essentiel de votre adn que nous avons
manqué
je crois pas parce qu'il ya la famille y
aller ce soir il ya l'engagement
politique il y a
des rencontres et
je crois pas qu'il ment quoi que ce soit
mais peut-être je pense en tous les cas
cette émission est cet exercice est
vraiment je vous remercie très très
intéressant c'est aussi peut-être faire
comprendre ce qui peut motiver quelqu'un
a continué à faire de la politique et la
politique c'est pas quelque chose de ça
la politique c'est quelque chose qui
parle de soi c'est pas utilitariste
sinon ça sert à rien et ça se finit en
général pas très bien mais c'est quand
même quelque chose qui vise aussi à
transformer voilà moi j'ai envie de
changer jeudi changer d'avenir c'est mon
slogan mais j'ai envie d'aider à changer
et d'aider les plus modestes ceux qui
n'ont pas la chance d'être dans ce
fauteuil à parler à évoquer cette
histoire est l'avenir de dire voilà je
suis aussi votre porte parole et je la
force qui est la mienne que j'ai acquise
avec cette vie et cette histoire j'ai
envie de la mettre au service des autres
merci merci à anne hidalgo
[Musique]